peggy 18.
you want a demo oh we'll give you a demo
ever since we first revealed outriders
last year fans have asked when they
might be able to get their hands on the
game
and yes we can confirm that there will
be a public demo for outriders
coming february 25th 2021
and this won't merely be a single quest
or a 30 minute snippets
nope this demo will feature the entire
opening chapter of outriders
no holds barred it is huge with around
three hours of gameplay and brimming
with content and things to do that will
give you a great idea
of what the full game has to offer
almost looks like home
that's what worries me as if you needed
any further persuading
here are 10 reasons why you need to play
the outriders demo
hope you all brought your galoshes
number one find your class
all four classes in the game trickster
pyromancer devastator and technomancer
will be available for you to play
through the demo with to experiment and
find your perfect class
will you be a tank pyro or a dps
devastator
mix and match abilities give them a test
run and find what suits you
and there are hours of gameplay to be
had by putting all the classes through
their paces
once you finish with the technomancer
for example
why not go back and see what the
trickster has to offer
you'll need to pick a class before
playing co-op which brings us on to
number two multiplayer this is the first
time you'll not only be able to hop into
the world of enoch
but with the help of your friends too
outriders supports up to a three-player
team to tackle missions
explore the world and progress through
the story together
you can find a matchmaking terminal in
your camp if you're looking for
squadmates but don't worry
if you jump into a lobby in which a
player is further ahead in the story
than you
the game will warn you before you fully
join to avoid any spoilers
more info on matchmaking and online play
can be found in episodes two
and three of the outriders broadcast so
check those out if you haven't
already number three
cross play following on from multiplayer
is that the demo will support
a complete cross-play experience
this lets you play the demo with your
friends and other players no matter what
system they're on
the demo will have cross play turned off
by default as it's still a beta version
but just head over to the options switch
it on and you'll be good to go
playstation 5 xbox series x and
s playstation 4 xbox one and steam
on pc no matter your preferred platform
you can play outriders together
number four transfer your progress if
you try out the demo
and decide to go all in for the full
game you won't lose your progress so far
and can transfer it across
this even includes if you play the demo
on current gen and then buy the full
outriders experience on next gen as
players will receive a free upgrade to
playstation 5
and xbox series x and s versions
don't say we never give you nothing
number 5
an epic journey the outriders demo
showcases the prologue of the game which
introduces the
entire story this is a true rpg at its
core
all right tell me the truth you think
the eca's thought this whole plan
through
a mystery hides at its center where is
this strange
signal coming from what does it mean
the demo will give you a sample of the
epic journey you're about to undertake
number six side quests we won't restrict
you to just the main campaign in the
demo
it's warming with side quests which are
replayable
and will adapt loot and enemy skill to
your current character level
feel free to take on other missions from
npcs and really dig
into the layers of this environment and
its inhabitants
what happened here what does it [ __ ]
look like
we got mutilated side quests won't all
be unlocked immediately though
certain ones have criteria to meet
before you can tackle them good to see
you again
with some only becoming available once
you've defeated the solar tower boss
see if you manage to find and complete
them all
number 7 weapons shooting is
interwoven in the dna of people can fly
as a studio
with gunplay classics like bullet storm
gears of war judgement and painkiller
outriders is a continuation of
satisfying
shooting you might notice that you can
dismantle weapons that don't take your
fancy
in exchange for parts also you may well
come across all deposits throughout the
demo
these both relate to the expansive
modding you can unlock later on in your
journey within the full game
remember saves are transferred within
the same ecosystem
so feel free to mine to your heart's
consent and have that loot handy for the
full
outriders experience more info on
modding can be found on the outriders
youtube channel
so give the weapons a go whether you're
the up close and personal type or prefer
to pick off from afar
number eight powers but combat
isn't all about the guns
the anomaly storms on enoch have granted
you unique powers
evolving you into a species called
altered
as you progress you'll unlock more and
more abilities
that are exclusive to each of the four
classes from scorching waves of flames
to bending time in space to summoning up
an army of aiding assault weapons
to shoving a stone spike through your
enemy's spine yeah
you get the idea powers are prevalent in
the outlines demo
and cooldowns are minuscule now you
won't have access to
all eight powers within the demo you'll
unlock the first four
the latter half coming later in the game
try mixing up different combinations
and see what outcomes you achieve number
nine
create your a staple of rpgs and
let's face it the menu you probably
spend far too long on
is character creation and did you know
you can change the look of your
character on the fly
within each camp in the full game this
means you can evolve your look as you go
but even in the demo there's a camp
where you can switch things up
fancy a new hairstyle or adding a badass
piercing
get customizing number 10
play aggressive in outriders
the scared hyde and the hesitant die
because the key mechanic in the game is
that you need to kill enemies to heal
with powers on tap and four in total
that you can switch
in and out within the demo and yes you
can even hot swap them mid gameplay
there's no shortage of carnage to create
on the battlefield
light them up slice them into
employ a turret barrage or crush them
into dust get
out there outrider keep updated with all
things outriders on our social media
channels
remember to subscribe to our youtube and
join us on the road
to launch thanks for watching and we'll
see you
on enoch
[Music]
you